sesemblent difficiles à trouver
sosont en période électorale oùe
gogouvernement promet d'injecter
dede l'argent dans le commis.
- - Merci Gérald.
E Éric Girard est ministre des
FiFinances au Québec. Monsieur
GiGirard, bonne fin d'après-mid.
- - Bonjour.
- - Vous avez dit ce matin
ququ'on était dans le pire
dede l'inflation, en fait pour
lele mois de juin, mois de mai
etet juin serait les pires
dede l'année pour l'inflation.
AlAlors, pourquoi ne pas agir
mamaintenant? Pourquoi ne pas
dodonner une aide additionnelle
auaux Québécois maintenant?
ERERIC GIRARD,
miministre des Finances, Québec
- - En fait, lorsqu'on a déposé
lala mise à jour en novembre,
onon a posé un geste pour tous
ceceux qui gagnent moins
dede 54 000 $ en janvier et au
bubudget de mars, nous avons doé
50500 $ à tous ceux qui gagnaiet
momoins de 100 000 $, et ça,
c'c'était en coordination avec
lala déclaration de revenus.
DoDonc, dans les faits, les gens
viviennent de recevoir une aide
auau mois de mai.
- - Mais juin sera difficile,
vovous l'avez dit. Vous vous
atattendez à ce que ça baisse
ququand, l'inflation?
- - Normalement, ce que la plupt
dedes économistes anticipent,
c'c'est le sommet, on l'observe
mamaintenant, mai, juin et qu'on
vava avoir une lente décroissane
d'd'ici la fin de l'année. Avece
reresserrement des conditions
momonétaires des banques centras
mamais aussi avec l'amélioration
dede la situation en Chine.
PaParce que vraiment, la fermete
dede Shanghai exacerbait
leles goulots d'étranglement,
etet on a quand même des
memeilleures nouvelles sur ce
frfront, mais je dois dire qu'on
n'n'a pas de bonnes nouvelles au
niniveau de la guerre en Europe.
- - Mais j'essaie toujours de
cocomprendre pourquoi vous donnz
papas une aide à la fois au mois
dede mai puis à la fois au moise
jujuin. On va juste récapituler.
VoVous dites : le pire, c'est
mamaintenant. C'est le mois de
jujuin. Le pire, c'est maintena,
mamais on donne pas d'aide. Ça a
babaisser au cours des prochains
momois, mais là, on va vous donr
unune aide, enfin, on va promete
enen campagne électorale une
anannée. Quand le toit coule
chchez vous, M. Girard, est-ce e
vovous dites : je vais attendre
dede le réparer en espérérant
ququ'il n'y ait pas de pluie
ququi vienne?
- - Mais en fait, je suis en
dédésaccord avec votre affirmatn
paparce qu'on vient aider
enen janvier et on vienne aider
au m mois de mai. Et là,
popour calibrer l'aide de façon
adadéquate, nous avons besoin
dede l'ensemble des données.
EtEt ce qu'on a présentement,
c'c'est une moyenne pour les ciq
prpremiers mois de l'année,
unun taux d'inflation de 6,3 %.
C'C'est plus élevé que nous avis
prprévu. Mais avant de donner
unune aide pour compenser
popour l'ensemble de l'inflation
enen 2022, il va falloir avoir
plplus d'observations. Il va
fafalloir connaître non seuleme,
ilil faudrait connaître au moins
l'l'ensemble du troisième
trtrimestre.
- - Mais déjà, vous planifiez,
M.M. girard, bien, en fait
FrFrançois Legault a l'air
dede planifier. Ce sera pas une
aiaide, ce sera deux aides si
onon comprend bien. C'est-à-dire
ququ'il évoque un nouveau chèqu,
onon verra de combien, et des
babaisses d'impôts, donc vous ês
dédéjà en train de planifier
sasans avoir tous les chiffres,
nonon?
- - Mais c'est normal qu'on
plplanifie, mais il faut regardr
l'l'ensemble des horizons.
LaLa compensation, il faut
rarappeler que le régime fiscal
esest indexé. Or l'indexation
popour cette année est inférieue
àà l'inflation que nous avions
esestimée, que nous observons.
C'C'est cela que l'on compense
avavec des aides ponctuelles por
lele fait que l'inflation est ps
élélevée que ce que nous avions
prprévu. Ensuite, les baisses
d'd'impôts, ça, c'est un geste à
lolong terme qui vise à redonner
auaux Québécois du pouvoir d'act
etet qui tient compte que les
QuQuébécois sont les plus taxés
enen Amérique du Nord, mais ça,
çaça va être fait dans le cadreu
reretour à l'équilibre budgétai,
dadans le cadre de la diminution
dudu poids de la dette et surto,
d'd'un financement adéquat
enen santé et en éducation.
DoDonc, les baisses d'impôt,
c'c'est sur un horizon plus lon,
lala hausse du coût de la vie, a
totouche les Québécois maintena.
C'C'est pour cela qu'on a agi
enen janvier, c'est pour ça qu'n
a a agi au mois de mai. Et c'est
popour ça qu'on devra agir puise
lala façon est toujours plus
élélevée que prévue.
- - Donc, ce que vous nous dite,
c'c'est que dans les promesses
élélectorales de la Coalition
AvAvenir Québec, il y aura des
babaisses d'impôts.
- - Je ne dédévoile pas le proge
élélectoral aujourd'hui. Il y a
dedes étapes. Présentement, moi,
jeje prépare le rapport
prpréélectoral d'ici la fin jui,
ququi sera transmis à la
vévérificatrice générale pour
ququ'elle l'analyse et y apporte
soson évaluation, ses
cocommentaires. Ce sera divulgué
lele 15 août. Ça va donner
l'l'heure juste aux Québécois
susur l'ensemble de la situation
écéconomique et du cadre
fifinancier. Ça va permettre à
l'l'ensemble des partis politiqs
dede faire des promesses
élélectorales basées sur un cade
fifinancier neutre, non partisa,
etet tous les partis pourront
chchoisir les priorités qu'ils
veveulent présenter aux Québéco.
DaDans notre cas, remettre de
l'l'argent aux Québécois, c'est
cece que nous avions promis en
202018. C'est ce que nous avons
fafait avec la taxe scolaire, ls
alallocations famille, et on va
cocontinuer de le faire.
- - OK, donc je reviens.
VoVous dites : Pas de nouvel
arargent pour le mois de juin,
mamais on en a donné au mois de
mamai. Est-ce que le 500 $ du ms
dede mai et à votre avis suffist
popour contrer l'augmentation
dede l'inflation au Québec?
- - En fait, tout est relatif.
LoLorsqu'on l'a annoncé au mois
dede mars, il y en qui disaient
quque c'était trop, il y a en qi
didisaient qu'ils n'en voulaient
papas, et d'autres disaient qu'n
dedevait pas le donner à 6,4
mimillions de personnes. Il faut
reregarder l'ensemble des gestes
quque nous posons. À la mise
àà jour, on a annoncé 275 $ pour
unune personne seule qui gagnait
momoins de 53 000. Au budget
dede mars, 500 $ pour tous ceux
ququi gagnent moins de 100 000 .
OnOn a aussi aidé les aînés de
plplus de 70 ans à faible reven.
DoDonc dans l'ensemble on n'a ps
dodonné à ceux qui gagnent moin,
onon a visé avec le 500 $ une
memesure d'application générale,
etet là, on va observer le
cocomportement de l'inflation
ququi va suivre dans le reste de
l'l'année et on va pondérer
nonotre aide en fonction de la
réréalisations de l'inflation.
- - Pourquoi pas baisser les
tataxes? Monsieur Biden suspend.
EnEn fait, pourquoi ne pas
sususpendre les taxes? Joe Biden
sususpend les taxes sur l'essen,
dede l'Alberta l'a fait aussi.
PoPourquoi on le fait pas
auau Québec?
- - Lorsqu'on baisse les taxes r
l'l'essence, on a aucune garante
quque ça va être remis au
coconsommateur. C'est-à-dire que
leles baisses de taxes peuvent
alaller d'une part dans les mars
dedes raffineurs, les marges des
prproducteurs.
- - Donc, c'est une erreur
auaux États-Unis de le faire.
- - Je laisse les  Américains
dede choisir les politiques qu's
dédésirent pour leurs citoyens.
MoMoi, j'analyse l'ensemble des
prpropositions et c'est certain
quque si on modifie... Le fait e
lele prix de l'essence augmente,
onon dit que lorsque le prix
auaugmente de 10 %, la demande
babaisse de 1 %. Alors, si on
emempêche l'effet de substituti,
onon aide pas...
- - C'est une incitation
àà consommer de l'essence
sisi on baisse les taxes.
- - Si on baisse les taxes,
onon encourage la consommation
d'd'essence, c'est certain.
- - D'accord. Vous irez pas dans
cecette direction-là.
- - Non. On fait confiance aux
QuQuébécois, c'est-à-dire que
nonous, on a choisi de donner
unune aide directe, les Québécos
pepeuvent déterminer ce qui est
imimportant pour eux, soit le
papanier de consommation, le
papanier d'épicerie, soit plus e
coconsommation d'essence, mais a
pepeut être aussi rembourser des
dedettes et c'est aux Québécois
dede choisir leurs priorités.
- - Très bien. M. Girard,
memerci beaucoup.
- - C'est un plaisir.
MeMerci beaucoup